uh professor quick question i am done
talking to you
this time it's important i swear my
marriage is in serious trouble
and i took your previous advice you know
i became a better listener so it was a
step forward
well now we're divorced this is why you
should take these things with a grain of
salt
yesterday my wife won full custody over
the kids and
she's taking the house wow i didn't
realize you were so
up up to date on this wait wait you knew
about this
absolutely are you some kind of a mind
reader i can do that
i don't know if i'm comfortable with you
reading my thoughts
i guess we'll just do it deal with it as
it comes okay what am i thinking right
now
but oh my son right yeah you bet i'm
thinking about my son
my kids may never see me again they're
really excited about this idea
why do i keep coming to you for marriage
advice all you do is make a fool out of
me
no blah blah blah blah blah what am i
thinking about right now
blah blah blah blah actually i was
thinking about how blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah you know rothfuss
wouldn't do this to me
uh let's move on
you